most of us have way too many apps on our
phones and most of those apps are
constantly stealing our time and
attention five minutes and email
countless moments in facebook endless
notifications but a new class of mobile
apps want to help us unwind rather than
add to the mounting mobile pressure a
new app for iOS devices called paws is
one example it's a game where you drag
your finger across the screen trying to
catch tiny dots and accumulate them into
one giant block the lava-lamp light blob
grows eventually taking over your screen
it's slow this isn't an action game
don't expect to spend tons of time
entertained by paws the idea is to help
you focus and let your mind rest and the
creator's wanted to help users who
struggle with stress and depression but
it isn't a medical device and hasn't
been vetted by the Food and Drug
Administration still you can think of it
like Taichi for your digitally addled
brain and if nothing else it's a great
way to zone out for a few minutes
pause cost $1.99 and is available in the
Apple App Store now